there are people that that get annoyed
that the the help dogs that it's given
out a lot more easily now that it's not
necessarily just a physical thing but a
mental thing and anybody can go and we
don't like that you know I was a sports
Commissioner for seven years so you've
done it all
Racing Commissioner in California Wow
wait for like you NASCAR horse racing
horse race right Vice Chair and so I'm
kind of a stickler for rules is there a
horse is there a harm in abusing that
rule it's just unfair to the people who
play by the rules I see yes and I'm kind
of that sort of person and so I think we
should just change the rules allow the
pants right where a certain amount of
pets and you sign up early what for it
like you do for a good seat right or
something they should just come to terms
so it's fair for everybody throw me an
economy plus or say I don't pay the
extra money and draw the line at ducks
and peacocks and pigs right so you think
if somebody's like no I need this
peacock is my comfort animal you're like
look I love animals I love people relax
you don't need a peek okay I don't know
that might I might be wrong there maybe
maybe you should better bring a peacock
I don't know I have a pet that comforts
me you know it's a Japanese Hornet and I
wanna bring on a flight it's got to be
trained though that's the thing is like
people will go oh well this is my
comfort dog great obeys its it's sitting
there quietly it's not yapping it's not
biting people but when someone's like
this is my comfort thing I got yesterday
and I printed this paper off on the
internet and now it's like eating
people's food it's clearly not trained
you just bought this and then you bought
a vest and now you're trying to be like
it's it's the law and you're not I'm
gonna get rid of babies smart if you
have an airline delay like delays suck
but if you the three-hour delay and the
dog hasn't got on the bathroom and every
can bring a pet on there's like a whole
Plane full of dogs that need to go to
the bathroom and there's a three-hour
bathroom and throw a wee pad down can
you do that yeah why not
one more gemandsam catch up with full
episodes and interviews from celebrity
guests anytime on demand using the
SiriusXM app